this is Joo podcast number
25 with Eko Charles and me Joo
willink and once
again we have this
evening jod mik and if you didn't listen
to the last
podcast this is our first double guest
he's been on the podcast twice we went
so long on the first podcast that we had
to break it up into two podcasts but jod
had a lot of been through a lot of stuff
had a lot of stuff to talk
about Canadian Army soldier sniper
served in
Afghanistan member of the city council
up in Ottawa he's been on TV he wrote
this book right here
boom it's called unflinching the making
of a Canadian
sniper and he was wounded in Afghanistan
lost double ampute below the
knees and we talked about that on the
first podcast if you haven't on on
podcast number 24 if you haven't
listened to that one listen to that one
first so you get the context of what
we're about to go into
tonight but welcome to the show Once
Again jod awesome man thank you
appreciate it Echo Charles good evening
good
evening
so well this one since we already talked
for a long time on the first one didn't
feel like a long time no it didn't but
this time we got some we did get some
questions from the interwebs and it was
now do you strictly pull from Twitter or
do you get emails I get Twitter I get
Facebook and what about your Instagram
okay the problem with Instagram is you
can't copy and paste from Instagram
that's on my phone into the document
that I travel with and keep going so
Twitter is the one that Twitter's the
easiest one Facebook's fine too but I
primarily use Twitter to get the
questions from all the Troopers out
there that and it keeps the questions
short yes you have 140 characters yeah
yeah and we know I've got now so I have
something called the the quest podcast
question bank right which I've caught
captured every question that anyone's
ever asked me they're in there and I
just every time I you know you got a
chance of coming up in the lottery every
time nice because I go through it and I
go through all from the beginning and
just look for questions that are
pertinent maybe the pertinent of the
topic that I'm talking about that night
maybe it's pertinent to something that's
going on right in the world but I just
pick them and say oh yeah that that's a
question that people have or I'll see
repetitive question people a bunch of
different people will ask me the same
thing and then that becomes one of the
questions but that's kind of how we've
been doing it right so do you do you
find you get cuz you you know we I don't
want to Hash it out too much but like
your podcast went from non-existent to
number one in about like 6 days
something crazy like that like you you
left the Joe Rogan podcast right did
your did started your own hit number one
and like now like do you get too much
correspondence like how do you keep up
like I've noticed you are you're like
you must make Twitter a daily task oh I
have to yeah and I I'll be honest with
you I don't know how long I'm going to
be able to keep it up for yeah because
so you're approaching critical mass I'm
approaching critical mass where I'm
going to have to where I'm not going to
be able to CU right now I read every s
I'll probably always read them all I
mean unless it just gets crazy but I I I
at least read them and I'll try and
respond if it's something quick if it's
not something I can respond to
immediately yeah I'll just put it in the
question bank and would you ever
consider getting someone to do it for
you no like not answer but like take it
all in record it like so you don't have
to check yourself maybe I guess that
seems like something Tim Ferris would
tell me to do which is which is smart
tell you to hire a kid in Pakistan to do
it for eight bucks an hour right no and
maybe that's a smart thing to do the
problem I find with that
is I I wouldn't if I was wanting to talk
to me and I was one of the Troopers out
there I'd want I'd rather have take the
chances of not hearing anything back
from me but know that the guy that
actually read this thing was me I read
I'm 100% with you I've had people tell
me to hand my stuff over and I'm like
uh-uh cuz that's me yeah there's one
reason why I interact with Joo on
Twitter it's cuz I know it's Joo yeah
yeah and I think that's the feeling most
people would have I know I would have it
guess who you un guess who I unfollow on
Twitter when I realize oh that's not
that's not him or her oh okay so never
mind
yeah for me it's like if you're in a
leadership position and
you lead you send someone else to do
your bidding oo that's to me is not good
and I wouldn't like that if I was a
follower Yeah Yeah well yeah the whole
point to social media and the other
thing is I get a lot of you know good
feedback from people and also people
always like oh you inspire me and you
know what I say you inspire me too CU
there's people that are out there
grinding it out in their worlds in their
lives and I say man the world is filled
with a bunch of people not a bunch of
lazy Slackers that I'm used to you get
on the you get on the Twitter the the
Joo Troopers man they're getting after
it of them are charging they're not
getting on there and saying hey I don't
feel like I'm going to get after it
today I think I'm going to no they're
like it's 4 07 and I'm in the game and I
go damn I got to keep my game in check
yeah I love I love it when I see like
I'll see uh your cuz you always put the
picture of your watch when you wake up
yes I do and then I'll see like a
retweet with like you know somebody
else's watch and there's like a thousand
watches with like your picture and
theirs right next to it and I'm like oh
it's 68 am where I am oh look at that I
love you man but uh I ain't getting up
at four that's just me though I don't
have any legs so I got an excuse right I
don't accept it do what you want but
it's I feel the same cuz it's
like it's it's a duty now yeah you we've
put ourselves in a position where others
turn to us so now we got to turn to them
and if we don't show up uhoh who we
letting down I'm not it's not that I'm
letting me down yeah you know it's that
you're going to let down
all what do you got like 25,000 Twitter
followers or something about 40
something yeah that's 40,000 people that
are waiting for your 400 a.m. yeah you
know that's that's good but it keeps you
keeps you on keeps you sharp right keeps
you on the days I I say it I got days
where I'll look at my prosthetic legs
and I'll be
like the last thing I want to do is put
those things on today and then I'll
think about everybody else that is in my
position mhm and says and I get it
because I get the same thing right right
oh hey man thanks for being who you are
and I'm thinking about them well they're
going to get up so who am I you know and
I love when I like when I following guys
like you though helps me go I'm a lazy
[__] people say I get a lot done look
at this guy and then oh look at her look
at that kid oh man I better step my game
up yeah bunch of normal people I'm bunch
of regular people with regular lives are
doing what they can to get ahead and dig
in
and and and that does me up you know
that does me up to see people getting
better and and wanting to yeah I just
had someone today this this uh woman
came into the gy to my gym yeah and she
said they called me down oh there's
someone here to see you I come down and
it's a woman whose daughter is fired up
for the podcast fired up for the book
they actually they actually named they
have a CrossFit gym it's called CrossFit
OverWatch o I like me tingles yeah yeah
so they and they because of obviously
because of you know OverWatch as we talk
about in in the book
and so yeah here's this woman she was
like to be honest with you she was kind
of tearing up a little bit like that
fired up how humbling is it when
somebody feels like that around you it's
it's motivating to me yeah no it's think
that you can have that you like yeah in
my case me the Jody midic the guy who
just wanted to be a soldier
and somebody is that like fired up to
meet me that they're shaking right damn
well I I got to I got to keep I got to
keep my game up yeah and it's weird too
and we actually talked about this on the
podcast once is like don't put me on a
pedestal as if I'm something great cuz
I'm not man I'm not I'm I'm a I'm weak
and soft and do stupid things you know I
mean don't put me on a
pedestal but put yourself on on a
pedestal you know put yourself on a
pedestal and rise up yourself don't
worry about me springboard off my back
and go to a higher level that's what I
want to see happen that's what I don't
want I don't want people to put me on a
pedestal I want them to stand on my
shoulders and go higher and further than
anything I could ever do that's what I
like did it did it take you this is a
personal question on my end did it take
you a while to
say like when somebody would say you
inspire me and thank you for being who
you are did you accept that at first or
did you have to tell them like no no no
don't like you just said like I'm
nothing special but how long did it take
you before you would accept that
compliment without without dismissing it
I literally went right the first person
that said that to me I said no man you
inspire me you know because you're guess
what I've had a great life I've had a
great life and I'm stoked right but look
at you you're saying I inspire you look
at you inspire me you're a single mom
with two or three jobs getting after it
and by getting after it I mean waiting
tables uh working in as an admin
assistant and then doing some
babysitting at night yeah and helping
with homework and making lunches and and
and right oh so joo's really really no
actually you are yeah you're fired up
yeah I just I asked because it took me a
while because I I I had a real hard time
with people looking at me like that and
I actually would I would be like
dismissive of it at first I'd be like n
no what are you doing what are you
talking about I'm just I'm nobody
special like don't don't don't say that
and I realized I was being a bit of a
dick by completely dismissing their
feelings for for for the situation and
and then it was until I until I realized
though and then that's when I realized I
went oh this is this is real these
people actually do feel this and I'm
who am I to to dismiss their feelings
you know so I TR trying to use them to
be stronger and realize like you know
like this is real like people are
looking up to me so now I got to live up
to that role I'll tell you another thing
that I tell people when they say
something like that to me I tell them
look there's many people that have done
way more than me and sacrificed way more
than me 100%
And the fact that you think that about
me the only reason you think that about
me is cuz you know me you know who I am
cuz I stepped out of the darkness and
and into the public view yeah but
otherwise there's a bunch
of a bunch of
Warriors that they're never going to
know their name they're never going to
be able to say Hey you inspire me so
they're throwing that in my direction
and I tell them look you don't I don't
inspire you you get inspired by what I
stand for and what I
represent is thousands and thousands of
servicemen seals yes soldiers yes
Marines yes all of them yeah yeah that's
what that's what you're saying and and
so on behalf of all
them I get it cuz you know what those
soldiers those Marines those seals those
guys in Special
Operations they inspire me too and so I
think there's that's kind of the so it's
a give and take yeah okay yeah no I I
had to ask you because I went through
such a with with the legs and everything
I was just trying to accept not having
legs never mind that I had a woman come
up to me and say uh I had like I had
several actually but this this was like
maybe the the first I think she said I
lost 100 pounds because of you yeah and
I'm like first of all you don't even
look like you weigh 100 PB and I'm like
huh what what did I do I'm just being me
and and that was the one that really in
my mind like at that moment I went okay
there's I got to I got to evaluate
what's going on here yeah I'm I can't
just dismiss this as I'm just jod midic
anymore clearly clearly there's
something going on well I think your
story in particular strikes a real cord
with people because you had to overcome
some crazy adversity and by the way your
adversity while challenging as you know
well there's guys with much more
challenging adversity than you've had
tenfold 100 fold and so you know for me
it's a joke for you you at least get a
sense but you and me both know and we've
seen guys and we know guys that have had
it like I said infinitely worse than you
unimaginable unimaginable and so those
guys that get up with their issues and
press on and drive on look to them for
inspiration look right past me look
right past jod look at those guys who
are doing what they're doing and and
that to me is is where inspiration comes
from and so I guess inspiration is
around you everywhere it really is if
you open your eyes to it and you look at
what other human beings do it's it's
amazing yeah it's amazing I love I love
it I love humans humans are such we're
such a species that study you know like
so anyway I I I know we wanted to get to
the interwebs but I wanted to have that
discussion with you before we moved on
because uh it was just important to me
to hear that the discussion yeah has
been had Roger and I think it's yeah I
think it's uh I think it's awesome I
think it's awesome
and yeah like I said I see why people
are coming up and telling you that and I
agree with them actually well thanks
buddy all right make me
blush we going to get to some questions
from the interwebs now okay now I got
all right here we go okay mental
exercises to learn to control one's
pulse and breathing in really stress ful
situations or when very nervous what do
you
do mental exercises so we touched on
this very uh briefly in the last uh
episode which
was on the book and where I talk a
little bit
about sniper
training um visualization is probably
your biggest tool in in in what in my
experience train train the [__] out of
it train train train and when you think
you've trained enough keep training but
when you're not training think about
it think about it the more you think
about it
become in tune with yourself okay I'm
going to get a little spacey here a
little
earthy just sit
there cuz you know what you do when
you're
sniper you [__] sit there you have a
lot of time to yourself cuz you can't
really talk cuz you got a job to do and
what you got to do is you just got
to okay I know my heart rate is going to
go up here but I got to do my best to
make sure it doesn't overwhelm my motor
functions and you can control it pretty
me pretty easily if you prepare yourself
for that moment but it's all about
preparation training and
visualization um even like
even making the shot you know like Tim
Kennedy was on here right and he talked
about dry
firing consider dry
firing like this is your dry firing for
for your for controlling yourself for
your brain for your brain exactly and
dry fire your brain I like that and and
um it only comes from experience now I
guess there's probably some exceptions
of the rule out there that are just born
to be coldblooded Killers the second
they get behind a barrel but but but for
me it was it was visualization and just
preparing to accept the feelings that
were coming and also overriding them
because that they could still be
happening but you can still control
yourself with the right kind of
preparation and it's also a perishable
skill funny enough uh I
realized I don't know if that answered
the question but I no I think that's I
think that's good and I think for
me one thing that I that I know I do and
this is a I guess it's it may be
considered a
technique but it's like the technique
creates the solution let me explain this
to you one of the things that I do in
stressful situations there's something
that I always try and do and that is no
matter what's going on I try and remain
calm in my voice so when things are
going crazy I try and get on the radio
and say say hey we need two more people
over here not hey we need two more
people over here Roger so if you're
going to talk in a calm controlled
voice then you can't be breathing hard
you can't be excited you can't get angry
you can't get frustrated you have to
lock all that up and get it under
control before you open your lips right
and start saying something and so I'm
always very focused on I am gonna sound
calm cool and collected when I open my
mouth that way and when and in doing
that the only way to make that happen is
to do everything we just talked about
control your breathing control your
pulse control your emotions get all
those things under control and then say
all right we need two more guys down
here immediately
now and everybody goes oh okay let's
make this happen and coming from you
especially you're the in your in your
case you were the boss
so if you're if you're calm cool and
collected that translates to your
Troopers it absolutely does so when we
when and it would for us as well when we
were doing OverWatch you know six is 63
you movement to your left where where
are they at no no no no right think
about what happens when you do that so
if imagine if I went holy [__] six
they're on your left they're on your
left right I'm freaking out uh they
would it would all be would be lost but
you're that you're that voice cuz we're
over snipers are OverWatch we they the
troops feel better when they know okay
the snipers doing OverWatch okay we can
we're going to be okay so if I got on
the radio and talked the same way so you
know no okay yeah adjust fire 400 meters
North you know fire for effect Roger
that you know like you got to that's a
good point I never even thought of that
yeah I think airline pilots train that
too cuz you know when you hit the
turbulence and they're oh hey guys sorry
about that tur you know just go ahead
and put your seat Bel there actually if
you hear Sully the guy that landed on
the river he's like that yeah like yeah
we're going to have to bring it down I
think they they have to teach him that
because that's where people are so
apprehensive is when they're in the
plane my favorite part about that is uh
he's like yeah we'll we'll be in the
river and the guy's like uh say again
we'll be in the Hudson Roger out and
like the plane it's like real time
you're watching the video and he's just
like yeah yeah we're in the river we're
in the river that's oh man what and by
controlling his voice in order to
control his voice he's got to control
his breathing he's got to control his
temper he's got to control his emotions
and so that's what I do in those
situations and I'll tell you what if I
haven't if I don't if I'm not in a
situation where I need to talk I'll just
talk to myself be like okay you know
just say that in my head yeah all right
what is the next movement you're going
to I know we're spending a lot of time
on the first question but that's what
saved my life oh
staying if I had gone into shock dude
I'd be dead right and I say it in the
book I say I did my best to go into the
zone so I know I'm bleeding out and I
know this and I know that but in my mind
it was let the system do its
job okay everything's going to be fine
jod it's okay and I just I just kept
saying talking to myself you know
visualizing what okay so the Chopper's
going to come in you know and I just
visualized each step and my my but the
whole point to it was I couldn't have my
pulse you know Jackhammer otherwise more
blood's lost more blood L and then and
what happens right blood gets sucked
into your core when you go into shock
and and that sucks it out of your brain
sucks it out of everywhere where you
where you know I I needed to stay
conscious so so anyway long long answer
for one question but this this is also
something you know you got to learn
practice keep practicing it you'll
figure it out yeah and always and we
talk about this again all the time on
the podcast inoculate yourself to these
stressful situations that's right
Colonel grman that's the guy's name yes
stress inoculation yep inoculate
yourself to the stress so that when you
you get used to it yeah the more
stressful sit I mean training going
through training man they they put all
kinds of stresses at you yeah so that
you learn to deal with it and if you
want to learn how to that's your time to
practice controlling all those things
absolutely and I'm not trying to go
level seven Zen Buddha on you all like
you need to get in the mind state to
control your breathing like no it's a
practical thing it's a real thing it's
not a yoga thing
it's a practical real thing of hey get
calm down take a deep breath get
yourself under control now it's time to
talk and give clear concise orders that
are calm yeah or make that shot or crack
one off if you're in The Sniper Zone
whack a bad
guy all
right next
question what does jod think of the
soldier first
principal in the Canadian Armed forces
is expertise such as his being lost due
to
this oh I think they're talking about
the um universality of service which
means
uh everyone must be able to
deploy
so I didn't realize what it meant until
I lost my feet and instead in my mind
you know this was something else okay I
can't deploy anymore but I can go to the
sniper school and teach the next
generation of
snipers sure but you're not going to get
promoted and this and that no more you
know like huh I was supposed to get
promoted to sergeon like what what are
we talking about here so University of
service says if you are not Deployable
you're not
employable and you can't be promoted and
you can't get any courses and this that
and
everything so because of it we lose a
lot of corporate knowledge right so I
was like I said I was a what we call a
master sniper an advanced sniper and
that doesn't mean I get access to the um
Canadian Temple of sniper sniper them to
see the secret 13th scroll or anything
it just means I'm allowed to do the
paperwork and hand out qualifications uh
and stuff like that now it is a very
difficult qualification to achieve and
they spend a lot of money getting me
there and that value is completely
erased with my injuries so Soldier first
is if you're not Deployable yeah then
you're going to get you're unemployable
okay so under that system you get
however many years to recover from
whatever your injury is at that point if
you're not recovering or going to
recover they will then begin the process
to release you from the pain jacked
up they're convinced that
it's required because of the size of our
military where my take is I believe it
the opposite because of the size of
military you want guys like me doing the
training the guys with the experience
the guys who want to be there to train
the guys and can't
deploy for as long as possible now I'm
not saying put me in a spot and leave me
there for 15 years to become a
dinosaur but allow me to pass on the
knowledge I have and and and remain
useful right but but they and they say
you can for the for the limited number
of years and they they offer these
things that they call extend pensions
and that but you're not going to get
promoted so forget about a better
pension you're not going to do this and
you're not going to do that um and the
dichotomy as the word that I I I never
used to use that word as much I used it
I was one of the few people use it but
not nearly as much as since I started
listening to the Joo
podcast um the dichotomy of it is
that we our version of the Pentagon I'm
going to get in a lot of trouble for
saying this but as there's a whole lot
of people whose physical fitness
probably keeps them from being able to
do anything and they're not being
they're not getting not being booted no
and it's one of those like open
Secrets you know what I'm saying yeah
and uh and I'm sorry if people get mad
at me for that and stuff
but I'm willing to run half marathons
and and and do CrossFit without legs and
stuff like that and you still don't want
to promote me or keep me well I'm going
to point out a few issues with your
system and I I don't blame the military
right like the military is a system like
we said the big green machine will roll
on with or without you at some point you
got to worry about you and that's at
some point I just started worrying about
more about me than about than about
Mommy the big mommy
military and but then I you know when I
look back over my shoulder every now and
then and I go tell me that guy over
there is
deploying show me what show me his Med
Med chip how many pull-ups can he
do yeah and so anyway it's um I believe
it I'm sure someone somewhere thinks
it's a good idea but I think the milit
the Canadian Forces should
reexamine what it actually means because
it's very black and white yeah that's
and there's no room for um oh well okay
so here's an examp real quick example
and we can move on we used to have um
we're in no rush Jody we used to have a
thing we called acting
lacking so you were acting as sergeant
lacking
qualification and it would be a way to
like promote guys that maybe can't quite
get you know maybe they have an injury
or something and um and they got rid of
it as we went back into
combat basically yeah so you had all
these guys getting smashed in
combat now getting told like ah yeah we
can't make an exception so you can't get
promoted so I was one of them I was on
the cusp of being promoted Sergeant just
had to come home and do uh what we call
it's called a small arms course and
makes you an expert in all small arms in
the Infantry and how to train with them
to train
Troopers and then you get promoted
sergeon and when you learn some Sergeant
leadership stuff as well but um I was
number one in my regiment to go do it
and when I got after I got wounded
they're like yeah sorry man I'm like
well can I just be acting lacking so my
pension is better like like oh yeah we
don't do that
anymore yeah that's I can see why I mean
we're only in combat guys are getting
smashed all the time so why would you
want to promote him and you know
like the the administrative side of the
military can be very uh heartless
sometimes yeah and I remember when I was
in San Antonio telling this to some
medical Colonel and she was like huh
she's like I promoted a guy who's in a
coma the other day we don't we don't
give a [__] down here no if you if we
think you deserve it you get your
promotion because we know what makes
things better for you when you get
out so should I
be bitter about not getting promoted no
I'm I'm I'm over it but I'm bitter you
didn't get promoted how you like yeah
thank you but you know at the same time
there's a lot of amazing people in a lot
of uh difficult spots in of
leadership and you know you got to pick
your battles too yeah right so anyway um
well I'll tell you
uh as you pointed out yeah I that's
really good what you said about guys
getting promoted that are in a coma
that's awesome I can't speak to the
whole military I can say in the sealed
teams we did a we do an outstanding job
of taking guys that get wounded and as a
matter of fact one of my guys who was
wounded real bad ran job who was awesome
bigles and he got shot in the face got
blinded and he was like I'm staying in
he's telling me I'm staying in I mean he
wanted to come back to Iraq when he
before he found out he was blind then
when he was blind he still wanted to
come
back but um then like when we came home
from deployment and
everything and you know he's he's blind
and he says yeah I want to stay in the
teams and I talked I was uh I was
friends with the Admiral that was in
charge of all the seals and I said Hey
sir I know this might sound crazy but
you know Ryan Joe
he wants to stay in the teams and just
keep being a team guy and he's like
we'll find a job for him right which is
awesome was it is awesome but was he
gonna get promoted he would yeah he
would have just they would have put
found a job for him and he actually
ended up saying you know what kind of
came to the same conclusion that you
made which is like you know what I I
can't do like the actual job of being a
seal now he had tons of lessons he could
have passed on would have passed on
which would have been awesome
uh but he he made a decision hey you
know what I'm going to move on okay and
so he got out so what would have
happened no there's he I he would have
stayed in and I would hope you know that
was one Admiral who was a great guy who
had a great attitude and supporting and
supporting the teams and that's one
thing that that Admiral always said to
me this is an admiral I worked for for
about 13 months I was the aid to the
Admiral in charge of all the seals
outstanding guy but one of the things
that he would say during meeting and you
know get all these politicians that
you're talking about all these
administrative people that you're
talking about all the big bureaucracy
that you're talking about and he would
say he would ask them they'd go through
their big presentation about we're going
to cut this we're going to do that we're
going to buy this but we're not going to
buy that and he'd say how does this
affect the platoon
o oh like cuz cuz people would forget
that the whole reason you're there the
whole reason any of that infrastructure
anything is there is how does it support
the platoon
how does it help the seals how does it
help the machine gunner how does it help
the sniper out there or the radio man
the guys that are actually doing the job
that we have and I say this to
businesses sometimes when I work with
businesses and I see that their
infrastructures getting super big and
they're starting to impose plans and and
restrictions and I say hey remember what
you're here for you're here to support
this guy that's on the manufacturing
floor or this guy that's out there
selling or this this woman that's
working with the patients or whatever
business it is because it's very easy to
be in a leadership position and forget
about what the ground troops are doing
no doubt and that's a horrible thing
that's a horrible thing and in this
thing that you're talking about Soldier
first which sounds to me like Soldier
last because they don't want to take
care of the soldiers if they want to do
that because there's nobody better to
prepare soldiers for combat than
soldiers that have been in combat yeah
if I want to learn sniper you know who I
want to learn it from in Canada jod mck
you know I want to learn it from someone
that's like you if I want to learn how
to patrol I want to learn it from
someone like you I don't want to learn
it from a guy that theoretically
understands it right that's not the same
thing I want the real
deal yeah it it's it's a policy again
they defend it they think it's
necessary what are you going to do yeah
big green machine just keeps on rolling
all
right this is a similar question to one
we've already had but I'm going to do it
again how do you silence distraction no
matter how important to achieve your
number one
[Music]
priority on on
op when I was still a sniper I actually
had a much easier time of this um I'm
I'm I'm add in a lot of ways and
uh whatever I want to focus on ADD
doesn't mean that you can't focus on
stuff it just means like when the
teacher tells you to focus on something
you're busy doing other stuff and
so right it's not a deficit disorder
it's that I don't give a [__] what
you're trying to show me but that right
there that's what I want to look at so I
um I had a way of just I would like if I
had to watch a crossroad I watched that
Crossroad was my whole world and it
wouldn't matter what was now it doesn't
mean I wasn't situationally
aware but I would watch that Crossroad
like my my life depended on it or
somebody's life depended on it which
which a lot of times it did and
um if I have another what I what I found
actually and this is one of the reasons
why uh I'm starting to meditate again
I'm seeing a therapist again um I'm
listening to Joo podcast and reading
extreme
ownership um no I'm I'm being serious is
that I appreciate it in my civilian
postmilitary post wounded post
addiction
um phase world I've I've lost a little
bit of my ability to to to to push out
the input I don't
want I have a hard I used to read a book
a month at the at the minimum and I'm
not talking like a book I'm talking like
a
book you know that I showed you I had
the 33 laws of War uh in my suitcase
I've been reading that for three months
and I'm maybe half done I have a real
hard time now
um achieving that that zone of zero
distraction and I'm trying to get it
back because it's really I get a lot
done you know I have I have my my
politics I have the book I do keynote
speeches um I have my kids um I have all
my hobbies you know I'm I'm trying to
support veterans support Charities that
support
veterans and uh and I still get a lot
done but I could get so much more done
if I could turn off some things in my
mind sometimes and I don't know what
what's happened or what if this is what
an addict's brain is like now or if it's
just I'm always seeking something I get
bored easily that's part of the added
I've always had that but when I found
something and latched on to it I used to
be like just I was
100% focused until I became you know I
got as much of that as I could and then
I would move on to the next thing and
um yeah I I I got to be honest I've I've
visualization though going back to the
first question is one way that you can
do it and and I've started meditating to
get my mind
back into that state I used to do a lot
of yoga and I used to do a lot of
mindfulness uh not training I don't know
what people now it's called mindfulness
training back then I think it was just
called reflection or something I call it
jiujitsu yeah well when I'm done the
bodybuilding show in November I I will
start Jiu-Jitsu oh you you might
actually be starting Jiu-Jitsu tomorrow
uh my friend just don't hurt me
doesn't hurt doesn't everyone I know who
starts Jiu-Jitsu hurts something that's
why I'm holding off but and I would I
will definitely come let you uh ragd
doll me but uh my point is that I've
lost it and I'm probably the last guy to
give you advice right now on how to lock
out the world because I have to put on
headphones and crank music to get
through a
workout right now and and I know this I
know I'm detrimental in it and I and I
and I'm aware of it and I'm trying to
correct it and uh and it bugs the [__]
out of me it really does it makes me
feel like less of a person so let me
tell you about a transition that I went
through yes uh first of all before the
War uh the military sent me to college
so I had to go to college and I as I
said Earl or as I said before I was
super focused when I went to college I'd
been in the SEAL Teams for 10 years I
was a go-getter I was a hard charger I
was like oh you want me to read this
book boom I would sit down and just
force myself to read it
and then got back to the SEAL
Teams and like like when I went to
college I literally read every single
thing that I was assigned and nobody
does that in college Nobody Does that I
read every single page of every single
thing I was assigned during college
that's ridiculous it's almost a waste of
time it's almost embarrassing Ekko
definitely thinks it's a waste of time
but but it was because I just could just
lock my brain down and get it done so
then get back to the team and in the
teams officer in the teams you have a
lot of administrative paperwork to do
evaluations and after actions reports
and all these things and I would do the
same thing I just go on a lock down LOE
and my put my brain on it and boom I'd
go through it and just get it done I
would just be able to focus so like each
thing laser focus laser focus that
report done gone
give report done done okay okay so I go
to Iraq the first time no big deal I go
to Iraq the second time you know it's a
much tougher deployment it's guys are
getting wounded guys my guys are getting
killed and I come home and I get put
into uh running the training and with
running the training all of a sudden
yeah there's administrative requirements
and there was administrative
requirements overseas as well and you
know what we did locked them down and
got them done I get home and I remember
the first time I got to do I think it's
evaluations which in the military in the
Navy anyways doing evaluations is a real
pain it's a real big Administration
administration of or of all the troops
so at this place I was at running
training I had 100 guys and every one of
them is like a little mini term paper or
something it has to be perfect it's in
the person's military record forever
they're really stressful about it and I
used to have no problem just hammering
those things out so I get back from that
deployment and and I'm sitting down and
you know I start doing I'm like H this
is stupid this doesn't matter I don't
know why I'm doing this right why do I
have to do that kind of started saying
the same things that I would always brag
on people for saying like this is stupid
oh now your men are stupid you don't
want to fill out the report and take
care of your guys you don't want to good
write a good rest of their career is
isn't worth your five
minutes okay you know so I but I heard
myself saying this right and what and
what what the constant undertone of all
this was that this stuff doesn't matter
combat was What mattered and and when
you get back from that situ
where man your buddies are getting
killed you're getting wounded your
friends are getting wounded this piece
of paper it doesn't matter and you say
to yourself I don't care about
this and at some point and it didn't
took me maybe two or three months I did
what I had to do to get by but as I sit
there and I looked at
myself and I said you know
what the combat
doesn't
matter
anymore you're not in it you're not in
it right now right this is now what
matters your your mind was still there
my mind was still there thinking that
that was all that matters and like I
said on our last podcast actually it's
in the past and it doesn't matter
anymore so you know what you have to do
you have to be a man and you have to do
your job now and this is what matters
now
and that to me made a big transition for
me and it you know I haven't even
thought about this until until you were
talking about it cuz I remember what it
was like to to go from when I went to
college and when I was before I deployed
roding I would just be so laser focused
be be able to just burn through things
and then when I got back and it was not
there and it was all because I thought
ah this stuff doesn't matter this
doesn't matter it's it doesn't matter
what matters you know there's guys
getting killed overseas right now that's
what matters and I had to say you know
what no that stuff doesn't matter right
now and you know and also I was in
charge of training and I said what
matters is doing this getting guys
trained to go overseas and I became
obsessed with that and slightly
psychotic about getting guys ready for
combat I mean I Was preparing them for
what they were for what they were going
into and you know you could I'm sure
there would many uh seals that went
through the training that I was overall
in charge of and would attest to the
fact that I was probably PR borderline
psychopathic at that point but I think
that that's I want running my training
no offense dude but I want a psycho
running my combat training yep yep so I
think what go ahead okay you were just
going to say you think I think that
telling yourself and recognizing to
yourself why are you trying to do this
thing cuz you're trying to do something
because it does matter right it it has
to matter in some way even if it's just
filling out the paperwork to get your
license from the DMV yeah yeah oh that
doesn't matter oh actually you know what
it does matter you're going to get
arrested if you get pull you know it's
like no it does matter these little
things these little stupid meaningless
tasks in life they actually do matter so
you know what you do you line them up
and you freaking crush them that's what
you do that's what you do you line up
these stupid meaningless things and you
crush them and you use them as an
exercise in discipline they become in
exercise and discipline oh this thing
doesn't matter guess what I'm going to
crush it now bring it to me where's my
DMV form watch me fill this out that's
what I'm going to do so maybe I turn
like some little meaningless things into
a personal competition of discipline but
maybe that's how consistent are you
making that happen
though this is I'm me talking let me
tell you so for for instance since we
started the
podcast I I have to read you know
basically a book a week and then once I
read it I've got to go back into it yeah
you do like a book report and and go
back through it and and how is this
going to flow together what part so I'm
spending a lot of time on that right now
and I've been able to do it every time
so far okay um so I think my lost my
ability to be
consistent and that's that's what's
really bumming me
out like when I when I your book isn't I
mean it's thick but I should have been
able to read this in two or three solid
days of reading yes and I told you how
successful I was yes not very
and that bugs the [__] out of me and I
it's a it's a it's
a uh it's a fail it's a it's
a you know what though I think this is
It's a failure on my part I I I think
that this is the same thing that we were
talking about on the last podcast and I
think Ekko
said when you say oh you know what I'm
not going to finish this book right now
it's it I don't really want to it's sort
of like when you say oh I'm not going to
quit want to though that's what I'm
saying you say but I don't want to do it
right now I can push it off a little bit
you accept that you accept that
answer you accept that answer the
soldier Jodie right wouldn't accept that
answer would not do you selft talk not
really not really I'm not a guy that
says you know I'm going to do this I'm
going to do that I just do it right I
just go and do whatever that thing is I
think cuz you're
you kind of have become that so it's
more of like I mean put kind of crudely
that's habitual for you to just do it
you know remember how and it was I think
it was kind of funny where where I Ed
this example like how you said use it as
an exercise of discipline so I I said
this example one time where I was in
line at the grocery store and I had um a
12 pack of beer do we have to relive
this story right now and I was standing
in line and there was maybe three four
people in front of me so I'm like all
right it's going to be a for me to get
up there this beer is getting and you
decided you're going to hold the beer I
remember this story I remember this
story so exactly right but it wasn't
that okay and the reason I decided to
hold the beer wasn't because that
benefited me right then it it was an
exercise in mental T here's the C okay
we're getting we're way off the question
but physical tasks sure no problem yeah
because it's it's visceral it's real I
can feel it but to sit down and and and
read the report on the sewer charges
that are going to be coming in on the
tax report for the city next
year what's on what's going on on
Twitter you know like it's kind of the
same thing though really but I'm
wondering I'm wondering if my brain
hasn't replaced the oxycotton with
social media yeah like I had to quit
drinking
because okay now we're way off the thing
but the the hard cover came out last
September and the hard cover sorry of
unflinching uh the making of a Canadian
sniper by jod midic printed by Simon and
Schuster available on Amazon through
Joost
store.com click the link to Amazon
um but yeah okay yeah I already said I
already said it I already said it so
anyway the hard cover came out quit
drinking I drank every day from the day
it came out that so we had 450 people at
the event uh uh Kevin Newman my buddy
who's who's a he's a well-known news
anchor in Canada does an interview with
me on the stage and we get Standing
Ovation we go out we celebrate me the
president of the company my editor wait
we have a good good night the next day
if I wasn't having one drink I was
having 10 and that went from September
to the new year yeah and I was getting
fat and I you know I was sleeping in
because I'm hung over and I'm not going
to the gym and and I went hang
on what's going on because this is it
because I have my job as politician I'm
daddy you know I'm friend you know I'm
I'm I'm I'm Advocate and then you know
the the book is it's a job right you
know selling a book is a job full-time
job I need nine days a week and 36 hours
a day to do
it and so I had to make that's one of
the reasons why I decided to do the
bodybuilding thing because I'm like well
you can't drink and it'll be right till
November because I need that so I'm
trying to figure out if my brain is
looking for a new habit cuz I was
diagnosed before as like
anti-addictive if that's even a real
thing thing but I had a doctor tell me
once he's like you're pretty much an
anti-addictive personality like you
won't get addicted to stuff and here I
was addicted to
oxycotton even though it's a physical
thing more than a mental thing but I
still wouldn't trust me with a pill
right now yeah anyway I think we got way
off track but I just again and I don't
know what your therapist is going to
tell you I'm GNA tell you what Joo would
tell you though these little things are
things that you I know you know how to
do them you've done them your whole
career in the military you are watching
a crossroad and I know that might sound
exciting to people that are out there
that are thinking how crazy that must be
no there's times where Jody was walking
watching a crossroad and there was
nothing going on for four days yeah and
he was watching that Crossroad and so
you have that in you yeah you just got
to tell yourself that you know what this
stuff now this is what matters and how
are you going to tell yourself that this
is what matters it's because this is how
it connects to the Strategic pi picture
you can't say that this matters because
of what it is right in front of me just
like when you're looking at the
crossroads you're not thinking oh this
Crossroads is important because the
crossroads is important no the C the
reason it's important is because you are
supporting keeping guys alive which is
going to help a mission out which is
going to help the the overall strategy
win the commander's intent the
commander's intent the whole nine I'm
the commander now you are the commander
and also what's your long-term Mission
and that's like kind of you just set to
yourself like oh I picked bodybuilding
because I there you just gave yourself a
mission right so what's your
administrative Mission you know ekko's
made some big advances lately cuz he
started freaking reading books nice and
he wasn't doing that before but he he
got the long-term mission of like you
know what I'm going to learn as much as
I possibly can so you got a long-term
Mission with your constituents right to
be the best city councilman and
represent so when they ask you a
question you're like boom that's kind of
the S of psycho stuff that I would say
is like if anybody ever asked me a
question like when I was going to
college I if they ask me any question
about any of the reading I'm gonna know
it that's just a bizarre p uh o what's
that OCD thing to be like I'm going to
know everything so you have four kids
you train every
day you get up at 4 in the morning I got
to get up at 4 in the morning that's it
that's my answer yeah and sorry sorry to
Riff on you guys on that man like I know
you want to do the questions but when
that guy when that like the the the
first question was easy cuz I'm like oh
I'll just talk about what I used to do
and then that one was like well if I was
to try and answer right now I'd be lying
I'd be a liar and I can't I'm I have my
moments still don't get me wrong I'll
have moments where I'm like this has to
get done and I'll fire through a speech
or I'll I'll write a report or whatever
it is and then I and then I lose it and
it's like ah ah [__] it's gone and
that's actually uh reinforcing what I
just said so when you have a near-term
mission that you know what the outcome
you know what the result is you know
what the end state is you know what the
commander's intent is like hey you got
to speak beach in 2 days okay now it's
in one day you can sit down and
concentrate and get it done but where
you've missed the connection now is the
connection between these menial tasks
right right that don't mean anything and
how can I put them to a long-term
strategic goal and one of the long-term
strategic goals you can put into place
if nothing else is I'm going to
discipline my mind to do these menial
tasks like a
soldier and that's pretty cool oo that's
a t-shirt
yeah potentially thank you Joo so
whoever asked that question uh thank you
for asking it although I went off and
talked about me for the most speaking of
tangents echo is going to take a little
further out there no no it's not a
tangent it's what you said how you said
that's what a soldier does so that's
like a little exercising and I did this
be I did this in a couple of times where
like one was how I quit drinking was I
figured out and you can do this with
your diet as well I figured out that
basically through all the the stuff that
I read that you're wanting to eat junk
food or drink or whatever is your brain
tricking you because it's built to it's
evolved for a certain environment that
that environment doesn't work isn't
around anymore yeah so now we're in
environment of abundance it has to do
with dopamine anyway I came to the
conclusion that it's your brain falling
for a trick your physiology of your
brain falling for a trick makes you want
this stuff how he says how jaku says
that's not what a soldier would do I had
it in my mind I'm not going to fall for
that trick I'm not a sucker that's not
you know doing this is what suckers do
I'm not a sucker this it's just like
self talking to yourself so I
essentially shamed myself out of
drinking yeah just like he's doing the
basically the inverse into focusing you
know I just remember like I I'm the guy
that we in Koso I quit smoking in a day
mhm because I couldn't run up the hill
next to our camp I said well obviously
these things aren't good anymore
and I literally just I just I I even had
a pack in my pocket for like a week I
just like yeah oh yeah okay throw those
out I want that guy back and I'm in
search I think it's been 10 years since
I was wounded I think I'm going to find
him again probably on the stage for this
bodybuilding thing or something but yeah
I just I just couldn't answer that
question without talking about that
because I don't I wouldn't have been
truthful at this point in my life and
that's what's cool is maybe that
question right there was something that
is is forcing you to face that I mean
you might have had it in the back of
your mind but now you're going you know
what I can't answer that honestly cuz
I'm not there right now I'm not but I'm
going to get back there real quick I
have my moments so stand by people stand
by soldiers coming back online reboot
jod
3.0 all right next
question th this is I'll just read it
how you prepared mentally what kind of
discipline you had routines in and out
of
battle how I prepared
mentally routines in and out of battle
yep what kind of discipline you had and
routines in and out of
battle
um I'm going to fall back
on mental routine I think is probably
your your your biggest because the
physical one is easy okay you you come
back so ble doesn't mean you know you're
in gunfights all the time you know like
like we say if we're standing still
we're patrolling right you know it's
just a static Patrol so you know you got
to make sure your gear is good you got
to make you know are your batteries
changed right you got like there's all
the ways the checklist checklist check
checklist as a leader it actually makes
it easier I found because now I have a
reason to check their stuff and check
that their routine so my routine stayed
solid right because other I had other
guys I had to worry
about
um so rest is a big one I I used to have
to order my guys to go to ground because
they were so cuz there's only three of
us and I used to my Barry especially I'd
be like Barry you need to be useful I
need you to sleep so my routine was like
make sure enough rest make sure cuz you
know that the saying Mission before
man sure except when the man is the
mission so I need my man to be good and
going to say if you abuse your man too
much you won't accomplish the mission
yeah like you know you know you know the
sacrifice the body well let's wait let's
think about that cuz the body what is
what needs to get this thing done
there's only there's only three of
us and in our you know if you're a
sniper you're you might be alone you
might be with one or two other guys I
can't afford to have a guy run head
first through a doorway to get through
it because I need him to be useful after
you know if you have a platoon sure you
sacrifice Smith he runs through the door
hey okay you got 29 more guys I and go
through the door um so my routine was
always like you know make sure
everything's topped
up keep an eye out you know uh do the
che do the mental checklist and then
visualize Vis like out of battle I would
try to you know I'd be on my I remember
I'd lay on my bunk and I'd have my and
I'd always end up with my right foot
crossed over my left foot and my and my
and my arms up here on my chest and I'd
have my head back and I would be going
okay
so okay we go down you know and contact
left and I would try to like you know
visualize these things you know cuz as
the team leader I had the radio and I
was security cuz my boys when they're in
position you know my spotter is spotting
my shooter is shooting so like they're
12:00 mhm so I'm now everything else
everything the rest of the clock for
them and for
myself so I was constantly rehearsing
mentally what what could happen I'm
calling in I'm practicing a a call for
fire I'm practicing an calling in an air
strike I'm practicing a nine liner I'm
practicing um a just a grit what do you
guys do you guys use that term is a nine
line for nine nine line is a casualty
Evac uh call for fire nine line yeah um
no no but grit like group range
indication type of fire yep yep so my
first even with all the visualization my
first actual grit in a battle was bad
the bad guy over there it's supposed to
be
63 uh 300 by that
tree you know all you know um uh far for
effect or at your own time or something
like the calm cool collected voice but
you know the guy was like 40 meters away
and it was like and my sniper was
actually looking over him wav he's like
I'm you know I'm looking at that stuff
and I was like [__] it I just shot him
myself
but uh but my point is that even with
all that practice and visualization and
training you know that was my first
attempt um so I was always just trying
to make sure that my routine off off the
battlefield was putting my mind back but
in a controlled setting mhm you know and
and all and and then also like I said
make sure okay yeah how much sleep did
you get okay good good good and that's
the routine that you know you got to get
the guys to relax especially like for me
I had
to I just had to make sure cuz I only
had me and two other guys I couldn't
afford to lose one of them whether it
was to exhaustion or malnutrition or
dehydration or sprained ankles or
whatever you know so I just I just did
my best to keep keep that checklist
going and and visual and I would
encourage them to do the same I'd be
like hey what are you thinking about
over there oh you know whatever i' be
like hey why don't you to think about
you know remember when you made like
we're doing making that shot and you
missed or whatever like try and
visualize try and think about what you
did you know there's a lot of steps that
go into pulling the trigger you know and
and um and then you know just think
about that think about how it happened
and encourage that you know I'm I'm a
big fan of um of meditation and yoga and
all that stuff
like if any like I think in our side of
the world we've lost a lot of that stuff
and I know we try to get it back and got
people that do it are treat hugging you
know spandex wearing weirdos or whatever
but yoga and meditation and stuff like
that's all Warrior culture from the
past like you know like Samurai meditate
you know a warrior monks uh fasted and
prayed that's that's just
meditation and and they looked inside
themselves a lot to try and you know a
Samurai's job was pretty tough call him
a [__] for meditating make sure I'm
there so I can watch watch and and I and
I firmly believe that that type of stuff
keeps you functional for when you hit
the battlefield you know that self you
know as grman calls it the
self-reflection self inoculation as well
so that was my routine it was just a
constant rotation of thoughts and then
but the actions were always to prepare
the you know the the situation for what
was coming does that make
sense yeah okay yeah the one uh one
thing that I that's actually a like a
really practical thing that I
did that and that is I had uh this is
again this is just like a real practical
thing I had two CS right slept in a cot
slept in one cot slept in one cot the
other cot was all my gear and it was
just laid out gun body armor you know
everything was right there and when I
when I got dressed to go out all that
thing was empty and so never forgot
anything when I came back everything
went right back on the C same spot same
spot everything squared away so those
that to me was and I I figured that out
really quickly okay just going to I
don't want ever want to forget anything
here's what I'm going to do I'm going to
put everything that I need right here so
not I had I I didn't even think of it
around my you know how I said I would
sit there right foot over the left all
around me because we had a caught we had
aot we didn't we couldn't afford two
Canadian Army okay sorry man um but
around I had we all had 2x4s around us
because we were in like a a fob we built
ourselves and each nail had its so I had
my my chest rig my rifle uh my ammo
pouches and then you know like and then
all around and but that was what I would
when I would go through my stuff that's
what I mean like I would hang it up open
up the pouch okay everything's there
close it next pouch make sure top up my
mags all that stuff and I would make
sure sure I'd make get the guys to do
the same thing and when you're ready to
go out an operation all your nails are
empty that means you've got everything
yeah but the biggest thing with r like
people people call it routine and they
think there's magic to it right there's
not it's it's just making sure you do
the same thing over and over and over
again you know as as as magical as Navy
Seals and snipers want to be like it's
not really that it's not that mystical I
guess um it's a it's just a lot of
repetition you know the routine is that
you repeat the same actions because that
what's that's what makes you good at
them yeah and I was I was telling you
when we were driving over here at some
point how we used to try and do
everything yeah when you would
fire together five or six Humvees lined
up for an operation they'd all be lined
up ready to go and then everyone would
like get get the word it'd be like load
them up and then you just see everyone
would just get in the zone boom You' see
everyone get in the vehicles and then
we'd start the vehicles at the same time
there there's no reason to do that no
but there is I Pav's dog type thing
there's no there's no um definable
reason why you would do that but our
deal was you know okay starting up in
three two one start them and then you
hear all the vehicles start up at once
and it's just like all those little
things would all those little
disciplines would lend themselves to the
team being more disciplined those
ignition switches might as well have
been the switch in each guy's mind yep
yep as the as that vehicle is starting
everyone's brain is going to into combat
mode and we're together at the same time
synchronized from the word go when that
happens I love it when you told me that
that was I was like yeah that'd be the
most badass thing to watch bunch of Navy
can you imagine bunch of Navy SEALs load
up and they have vehicles all stared at
the same time I'd run I'd be like I'm
not [__] with these guys I'm out of
here it was it was an awesome site that
when my guys when I was a task un
Commander you know I'd be sitting on
bases guys were rolling out and I stand
out there and salute him like just like
old school right but and it's you know
it was uh and they I bet and they loved
you for it I love those guys but the
the those guys I mean every time you
rolled out in the streets of rad there
was a decent chance you were getting
blown up there was a you the gunfight
was almost guaranteed to happen but guys
getting blown UPS was a real issue for
you guys e and and I was thinking about
this
today IDs there was we had statistically
the most heavily ided Road in all of
Iraq was Route Michigan going from one
end of the one end of ratti to the other
yeah
and there was IEDs all over the place it
was I mean it was it was ridiculous and
we didn't hit any IEDs while we were
there which I was thinking about that
today cuz I was thinking about my EOD
contingent we had two
guys and I never told him like hey we
never had an IED thank you never told
them that so you credit them with that I
credit them with part of it yeah yeah
part of the briefings that they gave
part of the now there was some close
calls uh LEF Splatoon and a matter of
fact it's in the book when they the EOD
guys were watching the front door they
couldn't quite keep an eye on it but
they were they did a really good
inspection of it when they came back out
they're like something looks different
they went down there
12m ID that would have taken out I don't
know four or five guys uh there was a
time where we went over we went over an
IED uh the pointman navigator in the
vehicles was like hey I think there's
something spec
suspicious actually got out of the
vehicle to look at it we're like you
know looking back what do you think
about that decision-making process you
know maybe that wasn't a good one
anyways we decided oh I don't think it
is we drove over it and about a half an
hour later the IED uh clearance team
found a triple stack 120 so that's
everybody in the vehicle dead um if if
you hit it uh so yeah IEDs were a
massive threat the number of guys that
were killed and wounded by IEDs and
ratti was ridiculous there was a whole
there was a vehicle
graveyard you know vehicles that had
been blown up and then dragged back in
with I mean it was it was massive I
mean I want to say 50 to 100 vehicles
are just piled up and including M wraps
which are the Mind resistant Vehicles
those things are in there broken in half
what kind of bomb do you got to put
together to do that we yeah Mo we got
real lucky and I know this sounds weird
my rotation they had conventional
mines so any purse and any tank and
there was the occasional IED but it was
usually
SV uh and uh and in the city SV means a
suicide vehicle so um our uh our
regimental sergeant major and his driver
were killed by a suicide vehicle born
IED Y and I stepped on a landmine if I
had stepped on an IED I would have been
vaporized but the rotation that c that
replaced us our sister
Battalion that's when we the the
intelligence says guys from Iraq started
showing up and uh we went from losing a
tire maybe having one guy get killed
through uh penetration in the hull or
whatever to uh we had a whole lav go up
and seven out of the 10 guys in it were
killed and it was like like like that's
how quickly it escalated yeah and uh
suddenly it was an issue for for our
guys as well almost every vehicle we had
hit a land mine on my tour and that was
the only time I was ever really scared
over there when I was walking or in a
helicopter or even out on a four-wheeler
no problem but when when I had to drive
on the roads in a vehicle that's when I
was like my the pucker Factor was the
highest for me ever ID's man like the
and the guys that would go out every day
and deal with that [__] yeah the ID
clearance guys [__] man like my hat
always came off to those guys oh yeah
like talk about a nerve-wracking job
yeah right yeah what's that movie with
uh with the EOD guy I don't know Hurt
Locker Hurt Locker I'm everybody who
does that job says it's a total [__]
movie but like could you imagine though
that's your gig well like we had
embedded EOD guys with us and seals
usually have uh EOD Navy EOD guys that
are basically like guys our guys were
like they they go through our training
with us they go through they don't go
through the basic training the basic
Seal training but they go through
everything else and our guys they're
like supporters well once our guys our
guys were like other seals you know they
were that good yeah
and but yeah um it's not it's amazing
but and the guys that are with us
they're with us and so they're not quite
it's their primary job for us but it's
not their primary job right right
whereas the guys that you're talking
about the guys that did Route clearance
oh if anybody's listening to this
podcast right now and you did Route
clearance in Iraq or Afghanistan thank
you Joo and Jodie say thank you cuz you
saved us so many times CU we drove down
those roads all the time my guys drove
down those roads all the time and you
found all those bombs that saved saved
our lives and and so many lives kept the
supplies rolling kept even kept the
local populace safe and you know how
much credit and Glory those guys get
none not a lot none and the in in ratti
there would be the the big vehicle like
a buffalo you know Buffalo it's like a
giant mrap you have to climb a ladder to
get into it so there'd be guys in there
that would disable the bombs from inside
they had a big robotic arm and they
would do that but behind them would be a
contingent of Marines in Humvees and I'd
say what you guys oh yeah we're just
support I'm like oh get some Devil
Dogs Marine Corps doesn't play around
they're like oh you need you need
support cool just get Humvees and roll
behind it but there's going to be big
bombs blowing up yeah we're in the
Marine Corps yeah no Factor we'll deal I
love Marines Marine Corp is awesome
anyway questions from the interwebs
questions from the
interwebs can you tell us about Jody can
you tell us about your wife the medic
that helped Save
You Now you kind of talked about this a
little bit on the first podcast we did
together so you know what I I'll tell
you about her so atanta is um so I say
her dad was in the Army and he he he's
from Ireland he immigrated to Canada
joined the military and uh he was an
Airborne Commando and in Canada back in
the day like that was pretty much you
know that was our one of our most fierce
units and he commanded the jump school
which is like oh wow that's that's
pretty badass he did the American Ranger
course in ' 68 dang yeah some old
Vietnam Rangers were running running the
show not old they were young guys I
should have said that the these fresh
combat experience Rangers were running
the show you know they weren't playing
around yeah he got kicked in the spine
with a steel toe boot yeah and uh
finished with a broken vertebrae and uh
but you know so I always say she was
drafted into the military at Birth and
uh cuz she grew up on bases all over the
world Germany um uh I think South
America and stuff her dad ended up being
in a like Embassy security and stuff um
she became a medic at a high school um I
think she joined 17 as well she's a
little bit older than me um and then uh
she has more citations for saving
civilians than she does for saving
soldiers she happens upon she's like one
of those uh angels I guess that
just one a woman so here's one a woman
had a heart attack behind the wheel
drove into a ditch Atlanta was right
behind her drove stopped her car jumped
in the car pulled her out dead atanta
brought her back to life right there at
the side of the road no equipment
anything like that just skill skill and
determination went and kept her alive
until the paramedic showed up and took
over she got a decoration for that um
you know she helped save my
life and and and a lot of my friends and
uh one time we were driving and We Came
Upon a
scene and we uh we were in my truck and
Alo is still a
baby still in our baby seat and so I I
look up and I and I see it I think she
she might have been on her phone I don't
know what she was doing and I see
scatter of cars car parts everywhere and
one lone cop standing in the middle of
it like a squirrel and not because he's
scared or anything he's just he's the
only guy he's the first on the scene and
I look at and I'm like okay something
bad happened here and I and I see one
vehicle in the middle of it all and I
went Alanta they need you and she went
huh I said you see that van I they need
you she jumped out jumped head first
through the this van was crushed and she
went in there and there was a
four-year-old little three-year-old
little girl uh that had been hit with
the car was T-boned she stabilized the
little girl's spine
uh kept her alive until the fireman
showed up uh they extracted she she was
in command of the scene they they were
like they they I guess I was doing my
best to help the cop with traffic and
and stuff like this and uh and deal with
some of the other like minor injuries
and the fireman like the first guy to
put his head in he's like I I kind of
heard like well who is this and then all
I hear is alant like I need this and I
need like she's sparking out all these
orders like yeah okay hang on so they're
running they're getting all this stuff
and they get the board and they put the
little the girl the the the girl ended
up passing away unfortunately but um
zero
hesitation that's that's my wife [__]
hero and
uhing you know she uh retired from the
military last year and is going through
um she's probably going to get mad at me
for saying this but she's going through
what a lot of soldiers go through the
transition Oh you mean the thing we've
been talking about for the all all night
and all last podcast she just she's just
having a tough time figuring out who
who's atanta Gilmore if she's not a
soldier and she's a amazing mom uh she's
an amazing wife and um she's amazing
person it's just in her mind she needs
to find the new her and uh you know and
and I'm trying to help her the best I
can but you know I can only do so much
and at some point she'll figure it out
she's she's coming around pretty good
right now I think she's she's starting
to like volunteer a little bit here and
like get out and do some stuff and you
know I'm pretty you know I'm I'm just
proud of her you know for the most part
yeah you know that's one of the things
that makes that transition so hard um is
that you know before I was talking about
like combat
matters and then beyond that you're
doing this thing you you know for your
wife like she's in charge of saving
people's lives saving soldiers lives and
that's going to help this Strategic
Mission I mean what what what is going
to replace that for
her and the answer Alana is nothing
nothing's going to replace that yeah but
you know what you don't need to replace
it you don't need to replace it uh whole
stock replace that thing that's a
beautiful beautiful experience to have
had in your
life but don't let it turn
into a black hole right like like the
black hole the mass of a black hole is
some insane number just like the mass
and the and the power of this combat
experience is the same thing it's this
super powerful experience but don't let
it suck all the other experiences away
don't let it do that don't let it do
that so what's the what's what else what
matters now we know what mattered in the
past right but what matters now
that's the question and there's so many
things I mean you got two daughters you
got your dumb ass to take care of and I
am
dumb she'll tell you uh so what is it
what are the what are those things that
matters and what's the next mission
she's going to find maybe she's going to
end up being a paramedic maybe she you
know who knows maybe she'll end up being
an artist maybe she'll end up having her
own podcast maybe she'll end up being a
painter I don't know but What mattered
in the past is awesome but let's find
out what matters now yep and grab a hold
of that baby listen listen to Joo
now hold on to that thing and let that
thing grow yeah let that thing grow let
that thing feed off of the past and
bring something new something bigger
something that happening something
that's happening
now but that's my wife yeah that's
awesome you must be damn proud of her I
can see it on your face like I don't
have any decorations for saving
people you know like neither do I like
you know uh and you know and I think
about what I what I saw I saw a lot of
Destruction but honestly it was mostly
the enemy you know that I caused and I'm
like it's easy to step over him like he
doesn't look like me he doesn't talk
like me he doesn't dress like
me I don't even know that you know I
didn't know nothing about that guy step
over him carry on she PS
up let's just take my case she knows me
I'm jod I'm her buddy we watched a
Family Guy together I used to you know
her her ex-husband and I used to were
buddies you know like you know all these
things and and she would whenever she
would roll up to a scene it was to clean
up the mess the enemy made of us and she
knew most we're tiny army men yeah and
our we're we're a brigade for us is like
3,200 guys maybe maybe maybe 2500 in
2006 yeah so she knew most of the guys
that she put in the body bags or or like
in my case she says after they loaded me
on the helicopter and it flew away she
was just sad because she knew that what
I was going home to because of my
injuries right she was like [__] she
knew more about your future than you did
exactly she knew what a nightmare you
were about to go through she knew what I
was and who I was and what I was now
going to be like have to become an
accept and she says that she said that
in an she had never said that to me and
I read an interview she gave once and
she said yeah I just I I was just
devastated for him because of what he
was going to go home to this big tough
strong proud guy had to go home without
feet she's just like
oh and I guess she said something like
you know if if nobody else looks after
him I guess I gotta God damn it she
[Laughter]
did next question props to aarm
yeah you're
awesome kind of a next question which I
paired these two together because this
one relates to it how do you deal with
being away from family and loved
ones I'm uh I'm odd I always have been I
think this might be where I might be a
little bit like
you do you ever like I
just I don't really miss
people yes does that make sense yes you
know what I'm saying right I know I can
see it okay you know I I I don't miss
people cuz I know I'm going to see them
even my do I love my
daughters love my daughters and I'll
walk in the house and they're better
than puppies right they jump on me and I
get Daddy Daddy it's my the
seven-year-old still does it I get
kisses I get hugs I get where were you
you were gone so long but like today I
haven't spoken to them
and I don't miss them I know that
they're out there like but on a on a on
a certain level when I do get home I'm
real happy to be home yeah like you were
saying to me on the phone like you just
want to get home MH but when I'm away
from
home you're in the game yeah especially
for this I guess because I'm here to
promote the book and I'm here to hang
out with you guys so I'm like I'm
looking forward and it's like when my
dad was crying in the parking lot before
I went on my first mission ever
to me it was like what's the big deal
dude I'll be back in six
months and and you know my best my best
buddies you know the the guys that I was
happy didn't die in combat I talk to
them every 3 to six
months you know I just talked to the
leader of that green beray team that I
worked so much with just the other day
after two years of not actually speaking
you know couple messages on Facebook and
this it's weird for me yeah I'm very
similar I don't I don't feel the need to
continually update people or talk to
people and my best example is a guy I
went through SEAL training with did
three platoons with him at Seal Team one
was in training cell with him at Seal
Team One and he was my roommate that
entire time so eight years or so we were
and we we did everything together drank
together hung out together everything we
did and I got and then I got moved to
Virginia Beach for two years didn't talk
to him not one single time not a letter
not a phone call not a letter not a
phone call nothing came back saw him I
was like hey what's up man oh yeah uh
hey uh you want a burger with us you
know what I mean it was just like
nothing picked it right up picked it
right up and that's how I always feel so
um and I kind of do that with my family
at least and you know I'm assuming that
this person is a guy that's um thinking
about being on deployment without his
family and so yeah and and again what I
talked about earlier is I'm going to
compartmentalize and say and I'll tell
you this
is I didn't want to talk to my wife and
kids every day at all when I was on
deployment I didn't you could do it I
mean if you were if you were on base you
could do it I mean for those of you that
don't know overseas most places overseas
right now you got internet you got
satellite phone you can call home you
can I did not want to do that with my
wife and with my family when was your
first deployment uh 2003 2004 that was
your first one ever oh no no no I my
first appointment was in 92 93 yeah mine
was uh Kosovo
99 you called home on a you had one
phone it was 7c delay and you got 15
minutes a week maybe it was 4C delay I
just know like it sucked yeah there was
no such thing as email email in 99 first
of all I didn't even have an email yeah
and so there's one guy on base who is
the geek and he would go back to the
main camp camp where they had the inter
interweb and you had to give him your
email and the password and he would
download your messages onto a CD ROM
come back with it and print it off on
the clerk's computer for
you I wonder if our type of thinking
about it is a is a response from the
fact that we just didn't have it the
first time and then by between 99 and
2006 in 2006 I had a SAT phone in my
pocket for every everywhere I went I
could have called home all day every day
but I didn't yeah because I was like
well first of all it's a treat and
second of all I got a lot of work got a
job to do and I can't be worrying about
one time I was on the phone and a shot
went over my head hey Dad I got to go
hey you know and he's and then I think
uh um your guy Chris Kyle in his book he
talks about being on the phone and then
a gunfight starts yeah and his wife
listens to the gunfight cuz he forgot to
hang up the phone are you kidding me
putting your family through that but I
think maybe our our situation is that we
came from the generation where that just
wasn't an option anyway so I would love
to talk to some of the newer guys yeah
about this about this subject um I did
two I did three shipboard deployments as
a seal so we used to deploy on ships and
the first one I went on we didn't have
internet so it was old school you'd get
mail written mail but that was the norm
once every 30 days or 35 days it be like
mail call everyone would be all excited
but um yeah I think that that definitely
conditions you to not be addicted to
having that and I don't think you're
helping the home front either to call
every day and say I miss you so much I
can't wait to I don't know if it helps
the home front either I think it
actually is a little bit painful for the
home front I was talking to one of the
wives the other day of some of our guys
that are deployed don't get mad at me
ladies but I'm just saying well there's
a lot of ladies that are deployed too
nowadays true but I was talking to a
wife of a guy I know and she says hey I
haven't heard from some Ando for for
like four days I'm like huh I'm like
he's probably on op like you know what
he does for a living you know exactly
what he does for a living Ops can take a
while he's like he's like yeah but
usually he gets back to me and I'm like
obviously he's on a long op but their
condition now to always hear back from
you and you know what you you talked
about this in your book which is life's
going to go on yeah and I think that
that's something too that will help you
know if you're like for this guy that's
going to be gone for a long time and
how's he going to deal with it except
the fact that life's going to go on and
just be cool with that things are going
to change the things are going to get
remodeled there's going to be some new
rugs in the house it's going to be a new
piece of furniture the fridge might
break and she'll go get a new one
exactly and there's nothing you can do
about it nothing you can and just be
cool with it yeah if you don't like the
color she picks say thanks for getting
the new fridge honey thanks for taking
care of that cuz I was busy doing
protecting freedoms and democracy in the
world all
right next one what are your
workouttraining
methods I usually make it up as I'm
walking into the no okay um right now
because I am bodybuilding and I'm going
like I'm doing uh might be hearing from
Ekko here in a second he's the big time
bodybuilder do you bodybuild no no okay
so I've worked out since you know I was
16 with weights right but I always so my
first mission in
Afghanistan because I was a driver SL
bodyguard and remember animal stack yes
the supplement which was basically
steroids yes so we would order we
ordered a [__] ton of animal stack and
because we had a lot of downtime we walk
watched um you know like 24 of the
series on DVD and we worked out I came
home like bench benching like whatever
four plates aside is deadlifting like I
was like huge we l looked awesome what
did you
weigh 240 or something crazy like that
and and then I tried to get behind my
sniper rifle because I was not operating
as a sniper right and I was like H oh
God okay couldn't too big tried tried
rucking threw my ruck sack on and tried
to go up a hill Oh my God oh my God so I
had to slim back down I realized I'm
like oh being a meat head is not
conducive to being a
sniper um so I always tried to tailor my
body around being a sniper especially
after that and um but now uh like I said
I'm going to be 40 in January it's going
to be 10y year anniversary getting blown
up in January and I wanted to quit
drinking and I needed a new goal to move
towards so I said I'm going to get into
bodybuilding and if you know anything
about bodybuilding I don't want to look
like Phil
Heath I want to look like uh Arnold when
he was in the 70s 6 right when they
still looked human so you picked a
realistic goal yeah something something
where I might not need supplementation
from another country um and not that
there's anything wrong with it whatever
man to
me my my view on that stuff is if it
gets you to where you want to be and
you're not hurting anybody who cares
right it's your body do whatever you
want with it
um so but but for bodybuilding you look
good so I'm doing the physique class
which means you wear board shorts and
you don't necessarily have a routine but
they tell you how to pose like they like
I we want to see your abs we want to see
your glutes whatever whatever so you
kind of just stand a certain way and uh
and I take Direction well right I'll be
on the parade Square basically so you
look good but you're not really good for
much when you're in that condition so I
want the picture of me with a six-pack
I'll be 40 I'll have a glass of water
it'll all go away um and then I'll
celebrate the 10y year anniversary of
getting blown up and at least I'll know
that I've got like somewhat of the type
of body I used to have back okay all
that being said my training now is being
directed by my buddy Nick and I do
whatever he tells me and right now
it's chest and arms one day back and
shoulders another day and legs another
day can you squat
no how do you because that was my
favorite exercise of course of course um
but there's got to be some like modified
I do a hack squat okay there you go you
know you know the machine yeah so I
recently discovered it like in the last
six weeks I I discovered this machine
hack squat um before I was doing leg
press and uh curls I can't really do
extensions cuz the cuz the stumps are
different length mhm and where the pad
rests across my shins it puts too much
torque on my stumps got it so but then I
found this hack squat thing and it's
it's made all the difference so I you
know slap as much weight on it as I can
stand and and I just squat cuz it's
almost like a squat yeah it's pretty
close but I'm supported so my wife's
Atlanta's noticed to firm her ass there
you go things like that you know and so
anyway my my my routine is just that and
you know the food is I'm a big baby when
it comes to food
um I've never eaten my vegetables and I
don't care what Nick says or what my
mommy used to say I'm not going to eat
them that's what my food eats um you
know I'm a meat and potatoes guy pretty
much um and that's about it I'm the
worst um Eater of food like Fear Factor
with Joe Rogan's old show I would be the
worst contestant I would be such a l
well I might be able to pull it off
because I've eaten some pretty gross
things because I had to right but um
like
I just don't like a lot of foods I'm the
same yeah and I don't care what anyone
tells oh come on you just got to try it
I'm not I'm not trying it yeah I just
smelled it I I want to throw up get away
I just looked at it it's something I
don't want in my mouth how about that
okay how about you just get me the steak
without any spices or sauces on it like
I asked for and the plain potato I want
next to it yeah and I'll throw some
butter and some pepper on that bad boy
that sounds like a good that's like
that's what food tastes like and that's
what I love you know Atlanta makes fun
of me cuz my favorite ice cream is
vanilla I'm like my life is exciting
enough I don't need no strawberry
sprinkle bubblegum ice cream let bring
my vanilla maybe a brownie on the side
yeah I don't know I I I do go with the
uh mint chocolate chip milkshake
but chocolate what about what what so
you just literally so you're like steak
and potatoes do you are when you go to
this bodybuilding thing you're going to
have to drop a bunch of fat yeah so I'm
dropping the fat um what are you going
you got to do that by diet right that's
diet and so what are you going to do
what do you know what Nick's going to
put you on for a program for that we
start that next week you think he's
going to go like no carbs all fat he's
he's a proponent of the old school
bodybuilding where you never want to be
in ketosis really but he's a bodybuilder
we're going I want to get him to relook
at the physique stuff because you know
if you read Arnold's new update modern
book on bodybuilding or Encyclopedia of
bodybuilding which he rewrote in the
'90s they still went by the whole fuel
the muscle with the carb thing right but
they looked amazing so they're like they
might have been on to something because
you got to think about they were on the
juice well Arnold's most of those guys
they say in the 70s they weren't juicing
actually you're completely wrong those
guys were absolutely juicing 100% in the
70s in the 70s absolutely and it wasn't
even not like today not like today but
Arnold was
absolutely 100% on steroids as were all
those guys back in the day and they
weren't illegal yet but they ALS but in
the book he says he didn't really they
didn't really know what they were like
their effect they knew they helped oh
but they didn't have it down to a
science you you know what their effect
was 27 in arms or whatever yeah they
didn't have it to a science but they
were take they were absolutely 100% on
the sauce um and it wasn't illegal at
the time they no yeah that's right so
that might be where that idea comes from
of hey they weren't on anything they
were absolutely and on on stuff they got
so completely yolked Nick yeah they they
did look pretty when you you said that
earlier they like oh you I want to be
natural like squirtz and Egger in the
70s well they still looked human is my
point they looked more human than they
do now like have did have you watched
Generation Iron yeah I mean guys now are
just mutants yeah and that's great good
for them amazing but I I can't I need to
lose lose weight to be on Prosthetics
like I can't be putting on that kind of
weight so Nick's thing is um ketosis is
bad because you risk losing muscle mass
and that's kind counter to the whole
bodybuilding thing so the transitional
period you do risk that if if you're not
in ketosis so there's a TR and it varies
from person to person some people they
go through they switch over to ketosis
right away yeah and you know the risk
you know they don't they don't lose out
but some guys it takes week and yeah you
will lose muscle mass yeah like I'm not
that big yet at all but I I mean we're
still we got till
November and uh as long as it's you know
it'll probably be a protein heavy uh
with the normal carbs rice and potato
sweet potato stuff like that like little
bit of olive oil and coconut oil and
stuff you just go lots of
fat pretty good amount of protein no
carbohydrates
yeah yeah no so e but this is my this is
after the bodybuilding yes that's how I
eat anyway oh okay I eat I do love me
some pasta though and atanta and I will
crush a pizza like we oh yeah that's our
thing Friday night we get a pizza we
rent a movie on iTunes you know you got
to get the occasional Pizza it's
understood Pizza tastes good yeah yeah
um but occasional yeah but my my general
rule for myself is that it's it's it's
usually a high protein like low carb
diet and if and I like to eat like if
I'm not eating I I like to be taking
like a shake or something like every
three or four hours or have you tried to
intermittent fasting yes yeah how' you
like that um it's okay I don't mind it I
like it as far as convenience goes
that's a convenient diet I'm not eating
today I'm going to work more yeah and I
and I I did a I did a 48 hour fast a
little while ago just out of Randomness
like one day I worked all day or
traveled or something and I didn't eat
and then the next morning I worked out
right away and then I had a phone call
and then I did something and I was like
dang it's been 24 hours I'm just gonna
throw 48 on this thing so I went 48 it
was no Factor you have zero intake or do
you have a Cofe no I drank water just
water drank water and you know what I
did squats rolled Jiu-Jitsu both days
the other day it was no Factor yeah I
did um I'll do I did a 48 hour but I had
coffee did you feel all right oh was
fine I felt fine I like I had a little
bit of tightness for a bit yeah but like
whatever like in the stomach yeah and
I'll tell you once you read The
Forgotten Highlander or any of these
books where I'm talking about these
people that are just going months
without food or the the people up in
North Korea eating uh what is it root
and saltwater
soup that's your meal God oh we we found
some weeds out there do you ever have
the dichotomy in your mind of if I was a
caveman I'd be fine but then you realize
it's 2016 and why are you depriving
yourself of something or why aren't you
taking full advantage of the of the
technology available to you whether it's
protein shakes or or or supplements like
on it I feel like like you know what I
mean yeah yeah I I agree with you on
those points but a lot of people think
that the benefits of 2016 are a Twinkie
you know or you know a bag of potato
chips or whatever and that's not my kids
up from school yesterday and I was
sitting in the office waiting for them
to come down and then there's this young
fell sitting over there by the next to
the principal's office eating his lunch
I assume cuz he can't be trusted around
other kids at lunch or something I don't
know what what the deal is and he pulled
a Twinkie out of his lunch I almost fell
over who gives their kid a Twinkie at
lunch yeah and it's funny that's
supposed to be Christmas yeah but when
we were kids when we when I was a kid I
don't know about you when I was a kid oh
you're thirsty here's a Coke oh you're
still thirsty here's another Coke oh
you're hungry potato chips like my mom
would read the ingredients on stuff and
be like oh there's way too much sugar in
this [__] I got Cocoa Puffs for my
birthday my parents oh I was I was Rice
Krispies and corn flakes the rest of the
time yeah thank you Mom yeah I was Lucky
Charms I mean we just ate it and it
wasn't like my parents said oh this
might be bad that was just what people
bought when I was a kid no my mom was on
top of that stuff and I have that too
like you there's sugar in like a loaf of
bread now mhm yeah I give my daughters a
a two slice sandwich that's like 12
grams of sugar if they eat the whole
thing I'm like why is there sugar in the
bread and and like I'll be I'm not I'm
like an 80 20 guy whatever that you know
the 80% like 80% of the time I eat
pretty good 20% of the time I'm getting
after some crap right I'm a lot like
that yeah um and most of the time it's
because the other day I was I was doing
so I was at a them and I was traveling
and it wasn't it wasn't the pretzel
wrapped hot dogs that we are all so fond
of it was uh but I was legit hungry and
I knew I I was getting back early enough
in San Diego that I was going to be able
to get a workout in and then
train so I had you know had like a
milkshake and a double meat sandwich of
some kind where where some some random
place in the airport oh at the airport F
oh yeah dog yeah yeah it was good time
milk airport
milkshakes milkshakes are
tasty milkshakes are tasty so do you
make do you make that kind of stuff at
home though to try and trick yourself
makes what kind of stuff at home so to
trick myself into thinking I'm having a
treat right I got I get my Blend Tech
I'll put coconut milk in sugar-free cuz
you got to actually search for that one
[__] can't
just anyway so uh put my coconut milk in
uh I throw in a couple scoops of protein
I throw in a couple scoops of uh organic
sugar-free peanut butter which you got a
search out again did you know they take
the peanut oil out of peanut butter now
it's insane why do they do that to make
they sell it off and then they put the
vegetable oil in a so now you got to
search out real peanut butter thanks
thanks World anyway so I put in a couple
scoops of real peanut butter that I
geted the Bulk Burn and um and a cup a
scoop of glutamin but uh when I and then
I ice it right and then I spin it up and
it's kind of like a shake like a
milkshake send me the recipe if it
tastes good and I'll put a shot of
espresso in often and it just makes me
feel like I'm having a treat and so I'm
like oh that's my sugar tooth uh
satisfied for the morning or something I
I've said this before my my treat is my
treat that I give to myself is uh dark
chocolate and by dark I mean
85% it's it's almost bitter yeah and I
dip it directly into coconut oil the on
it cocon coconut oil I dip it right in
there and scoop that in and that is
money Yes sounds delicious it's so good
I'm going to try that so good and the
other thing about if you if you and I we
like broke out some Hershey's Bars here
milk chocolate you take one bite you
want another bite immediately yeah yeah
yeah you want another bite immediately
you don't but you do and you do it yeah
right you take you take a couple squares
of 85% chocolate and it's like it
satisfies it and it doesn't make you go
oh that was good and it and it takes the
it gives you the
satisfaction it takes longer toat the
dark chocolate I find as well don't you
find that it stays in your mouth longer
The Taste it's it's just a little bit
bitter get the dark chocol the coconut
oil with the coconut oil makes it a
little bit of just makes it so how have
I not heard this on your podcast before
I I don't know if I've said why on it
coconut oil by the way that I love on it
been using on it before it was called on
it but why their coconut oil that's the
one he got yeah it's it's the virgin
coconut oil
it's really high quality coconut oil
which is what I do and actually it's
good to in supporting on it I actually
do support this
podcast yeah so uh whoever asked about
nutrition it's um ah you know one thing
I will that was me that asked about
nutrition wasn't that no the question
was about working out we kind of delved
into nutrition okay well Joo um the
other thing my guts got destroyed by the
antibiotics in my recovery and it took
me figuring it out on my own like why
was I constantly having like um diarrhea
why was I constantly not like just an
upset stomach and then I started re okay
what causes it do I have IBS blah blah
blah oh no I was on six months worth of
of antibiotics killed everything in your
gun and then I'm had I've had staff
infections like I had a year one year
where I had like four staff infections
in my stumps in a row and it just like
just ham you know it just hammers
because I was getting sick and and like
so I'm like what's wrong and then I real
oh okay so now every morning I like I
keep a bottle of Kombucha in the fridge
every morning I just shake it up take a
swig I have a probiotic pill that I take
with that Swig and that's made a huge
difference and and I'm always seeking
out different ways to keep the the the
gut Flora happy you know so like apple
cider vinegar um apple cider vinegar and
kombucha and probiotics those three
additions have made a huge difference uh
in my in my system like my immune system
alone and then I like I just started
jacking massive amounts of vitamin D E
and C into my body um and then i' I've
kept a real close eye on like so as a
kid like you know when we were eating
lunch I didn't want onions or
mushrooms because as a kid I didn't like
them and I found out later as an adult
well I'm actually slightly allergic to
them so whatever your body tells you pay
real close attention you know because
nothing will screw with your gains or
your workout routine more than feeling
like [__] right and and so if you eat
something and you feel like [__] after
you know pay attention to that because
that can take a lot of energy away from
your workout and just from your day you
know like you go roll into work with a
headache because you ate something that
you're actually allergic to like that
can really mess with your mood so I pay
super that's so one of the reasons why
I'm such a basic eater is cuz I've
learned that that's how I feel best and
I function best when I have minimum sub
like minimum like additions to like you
know when you when you go to the get
breakfast right nothing better than
bacon and eggs in the morning until they
bring your home fries and they're
covered with Paprika Montreal spice [__]
all over them and and I'm like why would
you do that to my potatoes potatoes are
delicious with a little bit of bread uh
butter and and sold oh they come like
that can I have some without it o yeah
okay you know what keep your potatoes um
because I've learned that if I have that
go in my system I'll spend a good half
hour on the can and that's time I don't
can't afford you know so if anyone who's
like you know when you're a big part of
your routine is is the fact that you
have to have the energy and like just
not feel like [__] when you when you go
into the gym yeah so that's why by the
way just so everybody knows the
probiotics and there's there's bacteria
in your stomach that's supposed to be
there that's good for you yeah and
that's what Jody's talking about that's
why he drinks kombucha and has the
probiotic pill because it keeps those
things alive and what he was referring
to earlier than that the when you take
antibiotics it actually kills all that
bacteria and then that makes your
stomach not be able to that's why they
came out with the the yogurt a few years
ago mhm the uh whatever it was
called yeah and I don't know there was
that yogurt and they started selling it
because it'll replenish your your good
Flora yeah whatever
whatever yeah
um all right a few more we got one more
question do you ever have
doubts if so how do you handle them
yeah I talked about the doubt I had
answering that second question
um if you don't have any doubt I'm going
to be real suspect of you as a person so
we all have doubts hey hey folks sorry
to break it to you Joo occasionally has
doubts he'll never admit it right
but doubts are part of of Being Human
and if you're not doubting yourself
you're not challenging yourself either I
believe this is this is just what I
think so I try to approach my doubts
head on
unflinching you know did I have doubt
this third time I got sent into battle
school yeah big time
but put on the best uniform put on you
know get in the best shape polish your
boots to the highest standard be
prepared to get [__] on and and and
Bulldog your way through and smile while
you're eating that [__] sandwich you
know like the doubt
is you ever heard that like you ever
talk to someone and they talk about what
they want they really want to be doing
okay so I have a I have a buddy of mine
he's a cop but he really wants to sell
t-shirts and he's like yeah well you
know I'm just waiting I'm there's you
know there's a time there's a time he
even made a t-shirt for me and he's
probably going to listen to this and he
knows who he is and bro I told you this
at the time he said let's sign a
contract for 12 months and this I'm like
you know what um six months tops and you
know if that he's like why what's the
matter I'm like well I just I just don't
think you're going to this is it this is
where you are he's like why and I'm like
because you're not putting the eort like
you're a cop you're not a t-shirt seller
and he he you so he's doubting himself
to to take that leap you know did I have
a doubt when I put my name in for the
election hell yeah I did I've never been
a politician I was a gunfighter I was a
sniper but the I deal with doubt by
dealing with the
situation does that make sense yeah
because I want to know that I can a get
through this through it and if I fail I
fail that's hey man I fail all the time
I failed uh reading your book you know I
failed making to the airport in time
yesterday
but and I have doubt all the time but I
also have enough confidence in myself
that I'm willing to try almost
anything and I don't know if that's
really the question that was asked but
the answer is the same
because fear is the thing that holds you
back from almost anything in your life
was I nervous when I put my hand stand
up to volunteer to go on sniper course
hell yeah I was but where did I want to
be I wanted to be on sniper course um
was I nervous the first time I was in
charge of a sniper team going into
combat uh-huh but guess what there's
nowhere else I wanted to be um doubt is
your doubt is your mind telling you you
know to think about the things you need
to think about anyway right like the
doubt is there for a reason it's the
self-preservation mechanism and you need
to use that doubt to to put the thoughts
into your mind to visualize the
successful
outcome like we talked about earlier
visualization you know I I picture
failure all the time and then I picture
how will I deal with
it you know
doubt doubt to me is just a question to
ponder and then move
on you know so that's that's how I do
it I'm going to say for me I
agree that doubt is really how I know
that I'm pushing myself into a zone that
I'm not used
to
but like the
enemy I respect my
doubts I'm not afraid of them but I
respect them I'm gonna watch
them I'm gonna listen to them
I'm going to understand my
doubts but I'm not going to be afraid of
them yeah and I'm GNA destroy
them I get CHS when he talks like
that and I think
that's about all we've got for
tonight Echo Charles how can everybody
just step on up and support this podcast
Shea um well there's a few ways as we
were talking about earlier uh if you
want to do some Amazon shopping click
for a book called unflinching sure
unflinching and what what we do and this
is no exception is we all the books that
we talk about we list them on Joop
podcast.com we have them listed what
kind of what they're about and what
episode they're from and stuff like that
there's a link on there you click on it
boom you can buy from right there that's
the paperback right there paperback and
also one of the coolest pictures ever
taken of me yeah good pict I was
checking out your picture here and you
have that little fun meter patch you had
that thing
pegged for those of you that don't know
that weren't in the military that was
one to guys wear different random
patches and some of them are you know
proud historical patches of their unit
and some of them and if you get this uh
if if you order the hard cover it looks
like that you can't see it but on the
soft cover you can see jod got the
little and everybody in the military
knows what this is a little fun meter
patch and the fun meter is pegged
meaning oh I'm having all kinds of fun
here this a good time that's awesome
there they are uh paperback hard cover I
like hard cover me that's what I do it's
good but yeah do that so we'll I'll list
that one obviously um I can get through
Amazon and then if you guys like the
shirts discipline equals freedom and the
one with joo's head on it I'll get you
on too by the way thanks get one of
those if you want to support and then of
course do your shopping at on it in the
event of you wanting supplements that
actually work because you got to watch
out for supplements bodybuilding and
stuff a lot of supplements not regulated
they can put anything they want in them
and sell them to you so get on it
supplements my opinion Jo on.com
joojo 10% off get your shroom Tech I
think shroom depending on what you're
doing if you're doing high-intensity
sustained exercise shro Tech Alpha Brain
if you want to think better and cre oil
if you want your joints to hold up with
a passage of time do they still have the
shroom Tech immune yes yes they do I
love that one I find that one good for
when you're traveling you were into on
it even before yeah I forget what it was
called but audre cuz he was on Rogan
right like years ago before they started
on it and he had these two supplements
CU ARB used to like the
party take out from that statement
whatever you but that's what he how he
would put it and he had a supplement
called roll on I believe and it was
meant to like roll on to the next day
and you take it when you're hung over
and I started I ordered it and cuz when
when I was very sluggish and all that
from the St from my addiction and just
you know the whole immune like I was
looking for anything so anyway that's
why I started using it yeah they they
have one it's called new mood it's for
like oh I love new mood you know over
yeah yeah man they have some a lot of
good stuff for all kind of stuff and um
yeah man so get on that joot or Joo or
on it.com joaco 10% off boom and if you
want to hit up if you want to if you
want to keep hearing anything from from
Jody you can get him on Twitter
Facebook Instagram Snapchat he's all up
in the
game jod Minik mic Mi i t
i and the jod mic podcast will start
being posted on iTunes if not today then
very shortly that's right and today
being what are we Saturday this goes up
what Tuesday listen this you don't know
when people are going to be listening to
this right you can just tell them listen
check out the jod mic podcast Jody mic
podcast on
iTunes be talking about all kinds of
cool stuff on there that's Jodie Echo is
at Echo Charles and I am atjo willink on
all those things too Jody got any
closing words
once again uh just thanks everybody you
know this is a real honor for me to
share the same space as uh someone as as
incredible as you uh Joo and Ekko
meeting you has been a pleasure like
Quest it's uh my continued seek you know
I I have a thing I call I seek knowledge
you know I'm seeking the knowledge to
continue to grow as a human and learn
continue to learn who I am and it's
experiences like this that make it that
make it happen make it possible and just
thanks man this is this is this has been
awesome well again thanks for coming on
yourself and as I said before most
importantly thank you for your
service the world is a better place for
what you did in the Army and for what
you have done and are doing with your
life it's an inspiration to everybody
that hears it and knows it
and everybody else that's out there
listening all those
Troopers I tell you go do the same
thing go follow the example set by jod
mck and so many other Brave veterans and
brave people in the world that face
their demons whatever those demons are
they face them and overcome them
and make the
world a better place by making
themselves better
people so go out there make yourself
better look that demon in the
eye and get after
it and until next time this is Ekko and
Jodie and Joo
[Music]
out